Now this process of referrals, as you can see, can be rather slow. A
particular DNS query might thus require round
trips to multiple servers that are authoritative for
different parts of the hierarchy. The blue
server is authoritative for the root. The purple
server is authoritative for .edu and the
red server is authoritative for gatech.edu. Now supposing
we wanted to save the extra time in trouble of
these round trip times. This local resolver would typically have
a cache that stores the NS records for each level
of the hierarchy as well as the A records and each
of these answers would be stored or cached for a
particular amount a time. Each of one these replies has
what's called a time to live or a TTL that
indicates how long each of these answers can be saved before
they need to be looked up again. Caching
allows for quick responses from the local DNS
resolver, especially for repeated mappings. For example, since
everyone is probably looking up domain names such
as google.com It's much faster to keep the
answer in cache. So, given multiple clients trying
to resolve the same domain name, the answers
can all be resolved in a local cache.
Some queries can reuse parts of this look
up, for example, it's unlikely that the authoritative name
server for the root is going to change
very often. So that answer might be kept, or
cached, for a much longer period of time.
A typical time might be hours or days, or
even weeks. The mapping for a local name, such
as www.gatech.edu, on the other hand, might change more
frequently and thus these local TTL's might need to be
smaller. Now the most common type of DNS record, is what's
called an A record, which maps an IP address to a
domain name. But there are other important record types as well.